juste je voudrais vous parler de cette
histoire ce garçon de 13 ans qui a été
condamné à 4 ans de prison ferme pour
avoir tué son père avec une arme il y a
2 ans le jeune homme avait tué son papa
qui était très violent et agressif
envers sa mère après avoir bu beaucoup
d'alcool 4 ans de prison ferme sachez-le
pour moi je trouve ça inadmissible euh
je voilà je je vous le dis et je pense
fort à ce à ce à ce garçon
regardez en octobre 2021 un véritable
drame familial a défrié la chronique un
garçon de 13 ans mise en examen pour le
meurtre de son père le père de
l'adolescent qui aurait été alcoolisé au
moment des faits se serait montré
agressif envers la mère de famille le
jeune de 13 ans a alors décidé de
prendre l'arme de collection de son père
pour lui tirer une balle dans la tête
pour ce meurtre l'adolescent vient
d'être condamné par le tribunal pour
enfants à 5 ans de prison dont un avec
sourcil alors comprenez-vous cette
décision alors comprenez-vous cette
décision alors Gill Verdez dit oui moi
je ne la comprends pas je suis comme
Kelly la vérité je suis comme Guillaume
je sais que Gill Verdez va encore nous
sortir la la justice ça fait 15 fois que
je vous le dis hein ici autour de la
table on ne parle pas au nom de la loi
on parle au nom de son cœur d'abord hein
d'accord et son ressenti mais g Verdez
mais oui quand même et
Radwan le Batman de de de dingon là il
m'a convaincu à la surazat c'est bon euh
oui qu'est-ce qu-ce mais c'est c'est
intolérable les enfants qui sont dans
cette situation ils sont complètement
dépourvu d'être ce sont des victimes il
faut se mettre à leur place tous les
soirs et voit leur mère se faire
tabasser par leur père qui est de
surquix alcoolique et on les traite
comme des coupables ce sont des
et le pire dans que si nétait pas le
père qui éituraité sans doute la mère
sous les cou du père donc il faut être
extrêm toérant
en c'est de la légitime défense et il ne
doit pas être condamné il faut prendre
compte de sa situation qui est
extrêmement problématique justice de G
ver non mais t convaincu on va écouter
je écouter l'original à la copie donc il
il va nous dire pourquoi d'abord on va
dire pourquoi non après on va écouter le
vas-yah il y a des meurtriers qui vont
pas en prison parce qu'on dit qu'ils ont
des problèmes psychologiques on dit que
ce sont des malades il y a des viol
sont des malades et là on un petit qui
qui tue son père parce qu' parce qu'
violente sa mère et que luiême est et
que luême victime qui nous dit pas que
du coup ça lui a développé aussi des
problèmes psychologiques qui nous dit
pas enfin il y a beaucoup de choses fait
il y a beaucoup d'injustice du fait de
part qu'il soit petit qui soit mineur
que ce soit un enfant et aussi pour ce
que lui-même a subi donc moi je trouve
ça inadmissible qu'on dise que un petit
13 ans il a en prison c'est c'est
impossible pour moi je peux pas oui
j'entends parfaitement ce que Kelly dit
ce que vous avez dit pour vous c'est
défense sauf que le procès et le dossier
ont montré que ça n'était pas de la
légitime défense cy c'est pour ça que 7
ans avait été requis parce que
attendendsends c'est la légitimef mais
exactement voilà c'est ce qu'elle
dit
vasy peux plus moi lui mais sauf que ça
n'existe pas le problème c'est que
l'adolescent il a tiré d'accord le
médecin a examiné la maman et il n'a pas
trouvé trace de violence physique ce
jour-là donc ça a affaibli le dossier il
a été placé en centre fermé il a fé donc
son dossier a été très affaibli et c'est
vrai que c'est une peine exceptionnelle
mais pour moi elle ne paraî pas
disproportionné il a tiré avec une arme
à portant oui oui c'est sur fond de
violence conjugale mais ce jour-l on ne
sait
pas il se prend pour un magistrat en
fait là tu es en train d'essayer de leè
de trouver des bonnes excuses mais en
fait en réalité cette décision
franchement moi je vais te choquer mais
pour moi c'est un acte d'amour je pense
qu'il Essé bien sû bien sûr c'est un
seul coup le coup est parti on conna pas
très bien les circonstances mais c'est
un seul coup il pas il s'est pas acharné
sur lui c'était pas la première fois
qu'il la battait il la battait
fréquemment et puis il faut faut un
minimum de cohérence dans la vie je veux
dire on dit qu'on est du côté des femmes
battues par on est du côté des femmes
battues d'une façon générale on l'est
aussi lorsqu'on rend la justice là
l'enfermer pendant 4 ans simplement
parce qu'il a soulagé en réalité les
douleurs de sa mère je trouve que ça a
pas de sens en fait et c'est je vois pas
où est l'éducation donc je pense que un
centre d'éducation fermé un centre
éducatif fermé aurait très bien convenu
en l'occurrence peut-être pendant un an
mais 4 ans là c'est c'est c'est c'est
terrible
Terri le sens de cette décision de
justice en fait terrible terrible
terrible oui are je voudrais Daniel par
qu'on l'a pas entendu de moi c'est quand
on lit cette phrase et quand je vous
entends évidemment que on on a envie de
mettre n j'ai lu tous les détails il
était ils étaient avec il était avec son
frère ils étaient deux le père était
alcoolisé apparemment pas de trace
vraiment donc pour moi ça n'est pas de
l' défense non mais quand on lit les
détail il peut pas se faire justice
quand même tu son père d'une balle dans
la tête
parce c'est quoi la solution alors toi
je comprends
rienme je suis
désolé pas la
lé
père mais il était AC le fa tous les
so mais moi en fait je pense à ce garçon
de 13 ans qui a été abandonné par tout
le monde qui abandonné même maintenant
par la justice lui dit mais en fait
pourquoi tu as fait ça alors qu'il
voyait sa mère laassablement soir après
soir se faire tabasser par un père en
fait c'est hyper dangereux en fait s'il
l'avait pas fait c'est effectivement
comme l' dit Guillaume c'est la mère qui
sera
en fait donc en fait il a fait le pire
de ce qui enfin le mieux de du pire
qu'il pouvait faire en
fait ça veut dire que tous les enfants
dont le père bah leurs mamans peuvent
tuer comme
ça on veut dire que dans un dans un cas
comme ça totalement dysfonctionnel ce
garçon n'a pas eu le choix il n'en
pouvait plus j'imagine que ça fait des
années des années qu'il voit ça sa mère
qui se fait tabasser par son père
visiblement ben personne l'a aidé pas
d'institution pas d'assistance sociale
personne il c'est abandonné par la
société voilà il a fait comme il a pu
c'est affreux c'est horrible évidemment
qu'il faut pas que ce soit mais
l'envoyer en prison pour lui il va
prendre 4 comment il va ressortir mais
les mecs
pas g il
r C'est pas même pas comment il va
ressortir c'est que il a vu sa mère se
faire tabasser à chaque fois il a rien
dit il a rien dit il a rien dit et là
Jacques l'a rappelé peut-être qu'un soir
il a pris l'arme le coup il est parti on
sait pas mais peut-être qu'il l'aurait
peut-être tué 100ans femmes Daniel s
femmes qui meurent en 2023 sous les coup
non mais on ne peut pas envoyer le
problème le problème c'est même pas ce
petit garçon le problème c'est que quand
tu tapes ta femme tu vois au
commissariat elle elle dépose une
plainte une main courante au
commissariat on lui dit c'est bon allez
retourne te faire tabasser le petit il
en a
peut-être c'est pas la faute des
policiers c'est la faute de la justice
derrière les polici j'ai pas dit que
c'était les policiers les policiers
reçoivent les plaintes derrière ça suit
pas lui il a pris deux peines là çadire
que il va aller en prison il a sacrifié
sa vie là jusqu'à 20 ans toutes les
histoires
je veux je te dise moi dans toutes les
histoires qu'on traite la police à
chaque fois fait bien son travail et
derrière ben il se disent pourquoi on a
bien fait notre travail parce que
derrière
ça aurait faire encore une fois Daniel
il y a la loi et a l'esprit de la loi et
effectivement toi tu parles de légitime
défense et cetera c'est un c'est au cœur
du procès c'est est-ce que Jacqueline
sauvage ça a été également ça est-ce que
le fait d'être battu de façon régulière
et récurrente à un moment y compris
quand personne dans son sommeil c'était
le cas de Jacqueline sauage son mari
elle l'a battu dans son sommeil est-ce
que c'est aussi l question une question
à poser pourquoi vous là pourquoi sans
rigoler pourquoi vous êtes toujours du
mauvais côté non mais sans rigoler c'est
incroyable non mais je vous jure que
c'est fou est-ce que vous le faites
exprès ou est-ce que vous pensez
vraiment à chaque fois ce que vous dites
pourquoi mon côté serait le mauvais mais
parce que vous êtes toujours du mauvais
côté mais vous êtes toujours du mauvais
côté vous êtes toujours du mauvais côté
c'est incroyable pour me faire er par
vous et pour prendre des saut de fumier
sur les réseaux heureusement que je
pense que je dis quand même par sin
personne d'accord AC
vous vous dites toujours que la just
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
comme d'habitude mais comment fait que
vous êtes toujours vous êtes toujours à
côté de la place vous dites toujours que
la justice est trop laxiste là elle a
condamné je plus dire ça je v plus dire
ça alors je vais dire il y a une justice
qui qui
V a un dysfonctionnement excusez-moi je
suis désolé le mec qui aadé le jardinier
parce qu'il aurait pu tuer il il a pris
un an avec surc
de et lui et lui il a pris qu enfer mais
lui il dit rien lui il touour toujours
du mauais côté toujours du mauvais côé
toujours du mauvais côté et puis là je
pardon mais on arrête pas de parler de
de de se poser la question si les
enfants de 12 ans de 13 ans doivent
aller en prison et parfois pour des
choses extrêmement graves pour
l'apologie du terrorisme et cetera à
chaque fois on dit non ils doivent pas
aller en prison là on se retrouve face à
une victime un enfant qui qui vit un
calvaire et là on lui met de la prison
ferme tout est fait en dépis du bon sens
toutc pardessus tête